hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the curse
of Blackwater something's gone horribly
wrong with my webcam okay much better
now thank you
all right we're gonna just go ahead and
select the sewers because every time
I've tried to resume the game it's been
that weird bug don't know what that is
all about but hopefully it's not just me
someone else experiencing that it gets
worse the stench of the sewers
overwhelmed my senses I continued
regardless I need to open the three flow
valves and then start the water flow the
fluid will disrupt the mechanism
are we really mad okay so I need three
flow valves and someone said that
there's a new monster in this area so
goodie at least we won't have to deal
with the previous monster that's always
a good thing
hello lalala still trying to find the
regular old supplies the same time
trying to find this supposing flow valve
if there is a new monster I'm ready for
it would oh I thought okay that was just
a door nevermind I'm stupid I'm just
taking a look in looks very maze like
around here need hurry up cuz as with
the previous things speed is generally
important I don't see a monster I don't
see a Munchie monster just yet but I'm
gonna assume that it gets released from
its hidey hole as soon as I unlocked the
first flow valve or something hello man
what was wait
that's crowbar yeah got a rusted crowbar
alright almost missed that one okay what
am I looking for here exactly I'm
guessing that this is the way out so
even if I get chased I could probably go
out there I think this is a monster that
people wrote telling me will not stop
chasing you once it starts so the idea
I thought I heard job I heard that so is
there a monster in here now is that the
story I hear you hi let's go in friend a
friendly mister closing doors behind me
but I'm gonna start doing okay so I'm
trying to find a flow valve I don't even
know what a flow valve that's not
cabinet okay I don't even know what a
flow valve looks like I'm guessing it's
a big bread wheel that I can spin fastly
some acid might dissolve it what is this
amnesia are you kidding me some acid
really don't have any acid I picked up a
drill what the hell why do I need a
drill I'm guessing I need the crowbar a
drill and acid that is what makes sense
to me right now okay I just need to not
run into the monster okay is there
unopened dial I popped up in another
side of the area that I don't generally
need to be in hmm I can't hear him or I
can't hear that same voice I heard
before
rusty cabinet key does that have some
acid in the rusty cabinet I told I need
to know and now this is very alright
okay I can live with that it's very hard
to see what I need in these cabinets
I've been lucky because I've learned to
be very persistent when grabbing around
blindly ooh
whoo I hear that I need to get it to
something in old dorky okay I get that
was the rusty cabinet key that I just
used I heard him over there so I need to
not be going that way Oh new flashlight
battery but that's the only one I have
because every time I restart the game
from the level select hello hello hello
it takes away my batteries that I've
accumulated so I need to I need to find
some more but I haven't been able to
find any ooh I heard that I don't even
know what this module looks like but I
don't want to mess with him where is he
I heard him can't tell me I didn't close
door thought I heard him in there
oh I hear em right there scrapp battery
battery powder please please battery
give me a battery give me about or gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme a battery
give me a battery come on
okay so that's how they I said see over
there I don't know I don't know this
looks like acid cut drill need a jar
Hodge sickles Hyrum ah ah damn it it's
on arrow ARF mom give me Tama yeah okay
Oh oh lordy oh lordy Lube
here's your karma he took comment quick
yes finally getting batteries it's my
favorite my favorite batteries ever need
to find a jar though get the acid I have
no idea where I am though because this
is all kind of just a blur okay there's
near the front entrance of where I went
the first time so let's go in one of
these doors over here no that's not
let's not go that way let's go over here
in this story this door is much better
than that door is it I have no idea okay
yeah cool is there something in here
that I need like a jar the jar type
device with a glass that you could fill
it with fluids that it wouldn't erode
kind of like looks kind of like a jar
hi oh god damn it he's not gonna why did
I even need to open that door that was
just another entrance into the room I
was in but I didn't find anything in
that was dumb that was dumb that was
pretty dumb
that was very dumb yeah man yeah
goddammit and screw you guys
dammit that sucks alright I'm not giving
up until I beat this so I'm just gonna
have to be more careful I didn't even
hear him when I was but then I just
blindly booze anybody here first up in
the door I just scream my name out loud
as I can to everybody in the area
whatever I don't care just gonna get the
crowbar that way I can get the other
stuff that I need but there's I gotta
make sure I get all the keys in this
area there's the crowbar same place give
me the crowbar no keys I just got to
make sure that I don't miss anything
that is the most important thing hang on
we go I'm going around the circumference
of the area before I go into the inside
areas let's make sure that it grab
absolutely everything possible on the
inside on the outside before I go to the
inside I don't think I don't think I'd
be able to get away if he did start
coming after me so this is my best bet
at least that's what I'm thinking
alright there's the key that I needed
the rusty cabinet key and the cabinet is
inside very quickly somewhere I don't
know where okay no okay no heard that
okay where'd that come from
hey I heard you he's bashing around in
there so long as he stays in there I'll
be fine okay just a few more cabinets
left and I'll be able to go inside I
don't know if he comes outside okay he
sounds really close he sounds really
close so I need to use his crowbar to
get into a certain room that gets me
into certain area I'm gonna go on the
opposite end of where I'm hearing the
sounds and start on that section and
work my way over
it's just bashing through every single
door is that is that fair the answer is
it's not okay I don't hear him Sarah
these look like valves ooh he's close
why is he so close it's not fair damn it
battery okay I just gotta get around him
but he's such a son of a [ __ ] or maybe
it just patrols in the same area that
sounds like he's coming from everywhere
maybe that's it okay that's another way
out I hear him where is he
he sounds right there okay all right
okay we're okay
this was little it doesn't lead into
there okay all right so far so good
that's not a cabin I remember seeing not
before that was not a cabinet all right
so far so good
there's the drill some medicine
no batter whew okay he's over there I
don't think that's near to here but this
may connect you no it does not okay
we're good
you're right on that other side of that
wall but I don't think there's a door
that leads over there so I should be
fine for now
okay that's the acid or I need to find
glass jar seems like he's just keeping
to his own section over there hopefully
I will be fine
how many times have I told myself I'd be
fine I didn't open that door I think
that's the door then yeah
this was the UH yeah that door okay
don't see him should be fine
should be fine come on we need batteries
I need batteries I need batteries okay
there's a key there's the other key for
the old door at least the acid room
excuse me sir I don't think you bashed
down doors that are locked right I'm
gonna leave that one just leave that
like that cuz I hear him over there
hello okay so far so good that leads
outside again all right aha got a jar
I got a jar of nothing gonna get a jar
soon battery battery those look like
batteries okay we got three lights here
see three flow valves okay I got it I
understood that from the beginning where
is he I hear him always behind me okay
Rosella okay oh that was too close oh my
god there's like 10 bajillion things
here oh my god oh my god oh my god
try behind me come on Jesus Christ
that's not fair
yeah man oh that's not fair
watching how he even said he was right
by me but I didn't actually think that
he was right behind me
[ __ ] maybe I can get it done maybe I
can't I have no idea nothing in there
that I need where'd he go hopefully you
got trapped forever and it's gonna die
that's what I hope battery battery
nothing okay I have no idea
I've no idea where he is and I don't
care what's over here
damnit sat acid room again me another
battery okay I think he might have
gotten stuck which may have given me a
reprieve for a little bit of time
where the hell the room center we're in
before okay here we go that door is now
unlocked and knows something in here
that I needed no yes maybe so no what
the hell this all here we go yeah all
right got one of them one of them down
it's our anything in there that I missed
I don't know where he is but I don't
care
actually I care very much where it is I
may be the lucky son of a [ __ ] in the
world right now
this is kinda awesome okay I don't think
those are interactive uh-huh that's
another one okay I got to I just need to
get to the acid place where the hell was
the acid I remember there was acid
somewhere he actually stopped oh no boom
up he was right there I almost walked
right into a my I got a break from him
and I almost walked right into him I am
the luckiest son of a [ __ ] and I'm
gonna ruin and I know I know I'm gonna
ruin it because I can't I can't have
nice things
I just can't I can't handle okay I don't
know where the Frick Theaster room is
but it's gotta be nearby right ah
it's gotta be some acid
where was the acid I do not remember
he's not done this hole is he
so it is possible to lose him it's just
really really hard to do that sure him
he's stomping around outside or the hell
that put the freaking acid remember it
remember it it's here somewhere anywhere
I get it
we'd all crap ah who's right there is
the acid door but I don't have to he's
coming for me
he's it coming he's it coming quick why
don't tell me he's chasing me in the
music to stop does he actually chasing
mirrors is that just a lie perpetrated
by the government to make me think
wait I've gone this way I shan't I bye
let's just no music no drama no drama to
the chase miss I gotta get this I swear
and get this if I could just find a
freaking acid was that was that another
one that I needed to pull fudge nutters
where is he where is he hang on I'm
going around I got to go back in there
because I don't know if I pulled that
one already I think I did
oh hang on hang on did I pull this one I
don't think I did [ __ ] oh that's not the
one that is the original that I need to
pull I still don't know where the
friggin ah Jettas I've been everywhere
everywhere hog my last battery I've been
everywhere I swear I've been everywhere
okay let me look for any door that I
have not opened is ridiculous
for gosh darn dick ulis is he behind me
this door is on oh yeah the one door
that I have not opened drill it acid
click yay I got acid alright let's go
have a good time
it's that battery better come on I know
he's like right on my ass whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay that was not okay I got very
little time before my battery runs out
and I am screwed for life I know the
room is over here know where the room is
I've been by it enough no good guy you
better not be here no no no no yes yes
yes yes yeah okay all right I'm in
where's the switch there it is all the
beautiful sweaty oh you beautiful baby
give me a pattern give me a battery give
me a power fine screw it I don't eat it
don't eat it don't eat it I know where
the switch is then I'm out of here I'm
out hear me you hear me monster
I am ouch once I get this you are done
you're gonna be flooded flooded did it
okay it was in here oh I hear a Me's
nearby Oh baloney
Oh where was it who's here it's right
here here character get it yes all right
my flashlight went out I got to get out
of here I got it
hang on don't flood yet don't know Oh
fun May I can't say don't do it don't do
it man
I gotta escape I'm almost out hang on
hang on I know where to go I know where
to go a job at nowhere to freakin go oh
good golly no not that way
get get get get get get get get get get
get get get I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get it oh oh oh I'm gonna get
it over this way
then take a right and go out that way
I'm gonna get your ass come on I'm gonna
plan don't die please whatever you do
don't I just don't die man there's the
light at the end of the tunnel
he'll die or don't go towards the light
or go towards the light I'm not sure
one is more prevalent in this area
please please let me win I'm so close
yeah yeah flooded no portal to extra
dimension for you man I did that even
with the whole monster chasing me the
whole time I'm so proud so proud look at
me kaboom
take that Maternity Hospital no thanks
for all the babies you've birthed
however my mind rest easy knowing that
all the demons in that place we're
surely obliterated by the explosion they
had to be had to be yeah sure or so I
thought or so I thought why the little
girl why the little girl survived anyway
that was the curse of Blackwater
Survivor difficulty alot no thanks I had
enough of a challenge with that mode so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching I'm not gonna do yet but that
was actually a really really well done
mark Steen did a great job and all the
other people involved with that it was
fantastic um they they all did wonderful
wonderful work on this one it was
thoroughly scary um there was some bugs
here and there
it wasn't bad like as an indie horror
game I would rank it pretty highly among
those that I played before one it was
lengthy to it at a working save mechanic
there are a few bugs but that's okay
because there weren't that many and as
far as inexperience goes and story it
was pretty cool nonetheless I mean kind
of iffy on the story bit but you know
you do what you can to set up a good
mood and then a great ambience a great
scares I liked it hope you enjoyed
watching it so thank you everybody so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and we're
gonna wait because I'm gonna see the end
of the credits here just to make sure
damn haha there we go that's me ha ha ha
ha ha ha I'm in the credits oh hey I
once you have something at the end of
the credits there was kind of always the
AH from before ha ha ha that's the end
of it that was hard I didn't know that
the FPS crater was using this so that is
the official end so and you guys hear
that thank you all so much for watching
clicking and taking movies that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
um the bellows
oh there goes my other Drive oh whatever
file so easy level
why
no hardest part